Minigitarre.
Gitarre.
Riesengitarre.
2,42 Meter groß, 57 Kilogramm schwer.
Komplett aus Edelstahl und Messing.
Gebaut hat sie Martin Stuckert aus
Bordesholm bei Kiel.
Ich wollte experimentell rausfinden, wie so
was klingen könnte in einer gewissen Größe.
Wie klingt denn so ’ne große Gitarre, wie wird
das vom Sound her sein?
Eine Riesengitarre will
nicht nur gepflegt werden,
sie stellt den Nutzer auch vor
Herausforderungen:
Stimmen lässt sie sich nur
mit Leiter und Schraubenschlüssel.
Vier Monate Bauzeit stecken in dem
Instrument.
Als Erstes hab ich mir ’nen Plan gezeichnet,
indem ich mir eine Gitarre genommen hab,
hab die gemessen
und hab gesagt, ich bau die 1:2,4
… bau ich die in dem Größenverhältnis
dann später nach.
Und dann kamen so die Schwierigkeiten:
Welche Dicke nehm ich für die Zarge,
wie mach ich die Saiten da drauf?
Wegen ihrer Größe müssen mindestens zwei
Musiker die Riesengitarre gleichzeitig spielen.
Es macht sehr viel Spaß,
aber ist auch ’ne große Herausforderung.
Die Wege sind weit,
und es geht ganz schön auf die Finger,
man muss hohen Druck erzeugen.
Aber es ist auch einfach mal
was ganz anderes.
Auch der Transport ins Studio ist bei der
Riesengitarre etwas kompliziert.
Eigentlich baut Martin Stuckert
Klangkunstwerke für den Garten,
die Riesengitarre ist ein Einzelstück.
Bei der Umsetzung hat er sich auch Rat
bei Gitarrenbauern geholt.
Herausforderungen gab es genug,
etwa Schweißnähte,
die auf den Millimeter genau passen müssen.
Der erste Ton,
das war so ’n Glücksmoment, so ’n Gefühl:
Wow, was hast du denn da gebaut? Das ist ja
mal richtig scharf.
Im Studio kommt die Riesengitarre
erst richtig zur Geltung.
Martin Stuckert digitalisiert einzelne Töne, um
sie später am PC bearbeiten zu können.
Der Bass, die Länge der Schwingungen,
wenn … wenn du die Saite anspielst, das
schwingt ja durch die Größe unheimlich lang
und das gibt so ’n supergeiles Gefühl.
Die Riesengitarre von Martin Stuckert:
Das ist wirklich mal Heavy Metal.